Tomorrow NASA has scheduled another
attempted launch of his space launch
system part of the Artemis program after
having canceled the Craft's first flight
now Monday's mission was postponed after
a fault on one of the engines was
discovered well joining me now is Leroy
chow and astronaut and a commander
former commander on this National Space
Station New York love you to speak to
you thanks for being with us so just
have a little prediction how confident
are you this thing's going to get off
the ground tomorrow
tomorrow's looking actually pretty good
the problem they had on Monday the
engineers believe it was a faulty sensor
there was nothing actually wrong with
hardware and so the weather is looking
pretty good so as of today as of right
now it's looking like a good chance of
of launching tomorrow and then talk us
through the stages now then so if it
does get off the ground tomorrow which
we hope it does this is the first stages
this is the test launch isn't it to make
sure that this spatial system works as
it's meant to
that's right this is the first launch of
this rocket the space launch system the
SLS and also the first real Flight of
the Orion spacecraft
um it's 40 I believe it's about a 42-day
mission after it gets up into orbit and
does uh the the ground controllers
perform all their checks then they will
do What's called the translunar
injection burn placing the spacecraft on
its way to the Moon once it gets to the
Moon it'll do a circularization burn and
so it'll enter lunar orbits and spend
several days testing everything
unfurling the solar arrays making sure
it can generate electricity and the
other systems are working before
returning to the Earth and then they'll
conduct a very critical test of coming
back through the atmosphere and making
sure that heat shield Works to protect
the spacecraft from that intense heat
coming back from orbit you're the
leading edges of the spacecraft would
get up to around 3000 degrees Fahrenheit
coming back from the Moon you're going
much faster so the heat shield is going
to get up to about 5 000 degree
Fahrenheit quite a difference it really
is and I'm glad you mentioned the coming
back because obviously the Orion capsule
comes back but the rocket itself the
spatial system doesn't and and why is it
why did NASA decide not to make this one
reusable because as you know there's
commercial rockets that are out there
that are reusable so why is the space
launch system a one launch Wonder
that's right this rocket is entirely
disposable and that seems like it's
becoming a little bit more of a quaint
notion because of the commercial
launchers most notably SpaceX has been
recovering the first stages of their
Falcon 9 boosters for reliably for for a
few years now and so that's a valid
question why are some of these
components not being reused solid rocket
boosters for example are similar to the
ones used on the space shuttle there's
an extra segment and a bit of a redesign
but they are also not brought back for
refurbishment and reuse so this vehicle
unfortunately is very very expensive
it's uh the largest launch vehicle we've
ever built on the other hand it's the
most important expensive launch vehicle
uh that's that we've ever planned to
operate NASA's office of Inspector
General estimates it'll be somewhere
around 4.1 billion dollars or so per
launch which is a lot more than the
space shuttle uh price tag at the end of
its life of around 800 million per
launch I mean you kind of touched a bit
on it there early right I mean the cost
of it is astronomical not an excuse upon
yes it really is and that's unfortunate
it's it's a uh you know what you're
looking at is it took a long time to get
where we are today for NASA this program
started in one form or another in
2004-2005 and then got a complete
redesign in 2009-2010 in fact that was
part of that committee that White House
committee the review of U.S human space
flight plans committee and then this
rocket came out of that and it was 12
years in development so it's taken a lot
longer than those of us who have been in
the business would have hoped for for a
reference point NASA started in 1958 and
launched astronauts to the moon for the
very first time just under 11 years
later in 1969 you know NASA built all
its structure built uh Rockets trained
astronauts built spacecraft tested
everything built launch pads launch
control centers mission control centers
did all that in less time than it's been
able to develop this this big rocket
that hopefully will launch tomorrow and
that was in the 50s and 60s when the
technology was uh obviously uh far less
advanced than we than we have now all
right we're looking we're looking
forward to tomorrow of course we are um
and eventually this will hopefully carry
people human beings back to the Moon in
a few years time right
well that's right if this flight goes
successfully then maybe in a few
in the future will basically kind of um
get on the same kind of vehicle same
rocket and go around the moon in an
Apollo 8 type mission that is they'll
orbit the Moon but not actually land and
then um you know it's frankly we we're
not sure I'm not sure exactly when NASA
is going to land humans on the moon
again because the Lander is still in
developments
um you know the funding is still you
know as you know here in the U.S funding
goes by uh election cycles and so while
I'm fairly confident we'll get that
orbital flight around the Moon uh you
know we'll have to wait and see when we
can do the actual Landing yeah I mean
the ambition is there and let's hope
that this uh spatial system carrying the
Orion capsule gets off the ground
tomorrow all right Leroy former National
astronaut and a commander on the
International Space Station really
appreciate your time today thank you so
much for being with us Mr chair thank
you